According to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics there are about 3.6 million
people
who are at or below the minimum wage
there working at or below the minimum
wage
and up where the create a couple grass
on it though pretty interesting
political
okay so who works at the minimum wage
teenage boys 10 percent I think that
make sense your first job cut grass
you know do in other newspapers miss a
newspaper boys that's what I did
adult women this one's crazy at minimum
wage
almost half those people are women adult
women teenage girls 14 percent
adult man 20 7.5 percent
now here's the fascinating part so 34
percent of these people who are at
minimum wage
have some college or an associate's
degree that seemed incredibly high
7 percent have a bachelor's degree or
higher
I 28 percent less than high school so
that I think make some sense
and a 31 percent are high school
graduates
so this there's some interesting numbers
you some I think kinda surprising and
some
not too surprising but the the education
one is the scary one
me I mean the people that are going to
college and still working
minimum wage the the scary number and
yeah I mean
stay in school you going to working in
which job is not the best encouragement
the
right that that they're not helping now
the scariest number
which was it was on those grasses that I
believe it's 56 percent
%uh minimum wage earners are full-time
workers
and more than half a minimum wage
earners
I provide most the income for their
households
yeah we have to decide if ur gonna live
in a society where a person can work
full-time and still live below the
poverty line but these graphs to show a
very valuable because the wanna do
most insidious arguments against raising
the minimum wage which a decent society
would do
eyes least we could do after destroying
unions which built the middle class
is that %uh they're all kids do in
summer jobs are starter jobs in S and 90
S
it's simply not the case so I assume
both you guys are on board the Seattle
idea the fifteen dollar
minimum wage are going to cupcakes and
rather at that church
address the one to pay people in
cupcakes going back to an earlier well
yeah
but I mean that's a separate issue the
week we're taping this of course is the
week the LA
that California's raise the minimum wage
from eight dollars to nine
San Francisco its 1074 an hour and if
you adjust for productivity
I and inflation the minimum wage today
should be twenty one dollars an hour in
Australia raised
there's to sixteen dollars an hour
unemployment went down
red it's gone up since then because I've
mining closer's by I
all the same doomsday predictions were
made and they were all prevent falls
every time they'd ever tried to raise
the minimum wage going back to henry
ford
instituting the five dollar-a-day wage
for his workers on
on the line at the fourth factory in a
also this will crush the economy kill
jobs
it's never true because if you're
employees have more money they're
spending more money in your community
and it drives the economy the middle
class
are the job creators and if we're all
gonna be low wage slaves
eventually there will not be high enough
walls for the 1 percent
in their gated community yes you know we
did a story in December about
literally at Walmart because they pay
their employees so poorly they were
taking donations
at Walmart for their own employees
pretty much deals
well that's the thing with wal-mart is
its price is so nice you pay from twice:
are you know go there I get subsidized
there are some stores were up to eighty
percent Walmart workers are on snapper
some kinda public assistance so you're
paying for those low prices
when you're there buying your
non-american a crap and you're paying
for it again every April
when you're paying your taxes and
subsidizing and that the sixteen years
at the Walmart fortune control as much
well that's the bottom forty million
americans
that's disgusting and it's not
conservative in its not sustainable
and it's not same yes so when we hear
all those numbers what what are we
supposed to do
because it's not change this is all
getting worse well what do you think we
can do actually to
to change the trend USA for actual
solution like some kind of resolution
yeah I mean number on logic into the
argument
failures is up rare yeah home no I mean
I think we're in the middle age makes
absolute sense I mean you have action
figures to back that up with which is
you know always a funny movie about it
sa mga
but I it's unfair you can prepare yeah I
mean is there really a question about
this than I think Braun agreement here
yeah why do you think women make so much
less than men still
you even in the white just said exactly
but even the white house this week they
show that the average man at work in the
white house right now
I think makes eighty seven thousand
dollars per year and the average woman
is making about 77,000 I get it there's
people have different jobs in there
might be some reason but what he did now
is it still women are making less it's
almost like there's like a disparity
between
one man may calm were made on a broader
scale
so it matches the White House I would
say it's not just the white house near I
want is a national problem may be unfair
to the white house you know women make
less because
that's what everyone's agreed to yeah
and when everyone stops agreeing with it
it'll change
but you know you want a real solution
get money into politics I'm with
Saturday Russian this is the only way to
start it
find a way to get money out of politics
look I'm not a liberal an eisenhower
republican
okay and why was the middle class a
strong in the nineteen fifties
everything Republicans hate now
strong union involvement yourself a
favor look as in nineteen fifty-six
eisenhower reelection posters it's
all about Republican support unions when
people have more buying power
you have a stronger middle class and the
rich do better to infrastructure
spending like the interstate highway
plan
are add socialism like the GI Bill and a
more progressive taxation rate the rich
have never paid lower taxes and
seventy years then today this is all
example
man-made policies goddess into this
income inequality mess and the policies
gets outta
out so it's not cheeses that's gonna get
us crash
look if we had a government based on
Christian values I would be kind to the
poor kinda sick
kinda prisoners and that Star Wars ya
tengo well pretty much everything
ever deal on this showing everything
using the news constantly
all is about money in politics to
actually go check out what their back
Dhaka
up